bonjour à toutes et à tous alors moi je
vous parlais des tic administratives et
je commencerai en rappelant que depuis
2013 suite au scandale cahuzac
la france a entrepris un important
processus de mise à jour et de
rénovation du dispositif déontologiques
qui à la fois en cas d' et réguler les
comportements des responsables et des
agents publics concernant les
fonctionnaires qui m'intéresse ici plus
particulièrement ce mouvement il a
abouti en avril 2016 à l'adoption d'une
loi qui est venu inscrire officiellement
dans le statut général de la fonction
publique la prévention des conflits
d'intérêts et la déontologie la
déontologie d'administration qu'est ce
que c'est si je la définit très
simplement ce sont l'ensemble des
devoirs et des obligations qui
s'imposent au moment de l'administration
dans l'accomplissement de leur mission
en france ses devoirs et obligations
sont exprimés à la fois par la bois mais
aussi par le pouvoir réglementaire par
exemple les ministres et le juge
administratif notamment à travers la
jurisprudence du conseil d'état
mais ce qui est important de redire
c'est surtout que ses devoirs et
obligations et déontologiques le respect
garanties notamment l'actrice
citoyen dans l'administration des
services publics et conditions donc leur
légitimité dans notre système
démocratique
je reviens maintenant mouvement de
rénovation 2013 il a une particularité
c'est qu'il a cherché à mettre l'accent
sur une approche beaucoup plus
préventive et moins répressive de la
déontologie administrative
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que on ne cherche plus à se limiter à
prendre des sanctions disciplinaires qui
vont venir réprimer des manquements à
des normes qui sont juriez au
contraignante mais on veut au préalable
utiliser des outils les instruments qui
vont prévenir les risques éthiques et
empêcher que ces mauvais comportements
de surviennent afin de vraiment
approfondir sur mouvement et promouvoir
les types de l'administration publique
je crois qu'il est important d'éviter
trois malentendu principaux sur ce sujet
le premier malentendu c'est que très
souvent on a une vision qui est négative
qui va être formulée en termes de
moralisation des comportements alors qu
il serait bon d'avoir une approche
beaucoup plus positive et stimulante de
l'éthique
une démarche éthique elle ne cherche pas
simplement à réprimer des actes
répréhensibles
elle s'intéresse beaucoup plus à aider
les agents publics
à rechercher la bonne conduite au
quotidien si je prends une métaphore
médicale
il ne s'agit pas simplement d'empêcher
les maladies il s'agit aussi de
s'efforcer d'être en bonne santé et être
en bonne santé vous savez parfaitement
que ce n'est pas simplement éviter de
tomber malade mais c'est aussi
s'efforcer pour être dans une meilleure
condition à la fois physique et
psychologique
donc il est vraiment important de sortir
d'une démarche qui serait simplement
ponctuel et réactive qui va se
développer amplement dans des cas de
scandale d' affaire de manquement à
l'éthique pour aller vers une approche
qui se veut beaucoup plus pro active et
constante
pour le dire simplement c'est aussi
lorsque entre guillemets tout va bien
qu'il faut se préoccuper des tic
le deuxième malentendu principal sur ce
sujet c'est très souvent une vision qui
est individuelle alors qu'il faudrait
avoir une approche qui est beaucoup plus
institutionnel évidemment l'agent il va
être amené à décider et agir
mais l'institution où l'organisation
elle aussi a un rôle central à jouer en
matière d'éthique
pourquoi parce que d'abord c'est elle
qui va déterminer ce qu'est une bonne
conduite elle va définir des valeurs
elle va dégager des normes de conduite à
respecter mais surtout parce que
l'organisation
c'est elle aussi qui peut être à
l'origine de défi aux problèmes éthiques
par son fonctionnement par son mode de
gestion grâce à culture plus informelle
penser une organisation dans laquelle on
a une tradition d'acceptation
pots-de-vin vous en laisse passer les
conflits d'intérêts on sort on ne s'en
préoccupe pas donc là encore pour faire
une métaphore qui est souvent utilisé en
matière d'éthique on parle de la pomme
pourrie eh bien j'aimerais vous dire que
c'est pas la pomme éventuellement pourri
qui devrait nous intéresser le panier
lui mais c'est pour ça que
l'organisation
l'institution est le central à jouer
pour aider accompagner soutenir les
agents face aux difficultés tic qui
peuvent se présenter à eux dans leur
travail par exemple en adoptant des
mesures des politiques de formation
formation initiale formation continue en
mettant en place un code de conduite en
mettant en place un conseiller qui va
venir les aider à prendre la bonne
décision
le troisième malentendu en matière
d'éthique administratif qui est très
courant en france c'est le fait de
penser que se conformer aux règles c'est
suffisant pour promouvoir et bien vente
hier un comportement éthique
entendons-nous bien il est absolument
indispensable d'avoir des règles qui
vont venir cadres et les comportements
qu'ils soient entendus de la part des
fonctionnaires et des agents publics
mais ces règles et vous venir simplement
posé les limites elles n'indiquent pas
concrètement ce qu'est la bonne conduite
où la bonne décision à avoir en
situation et en particulier dans des
situations qui sont complexes qui sont
ambigus qu'ils sont contradictoires et
notamment face à ce qu'on appelle un
deal avait dit qu un diabétique c'est
quoi un dilemme éthique c'est une
situation dans laquelle plusieurs
valeurs ou plusieurs noms sont en
contradiction et où l'agent à devoir
faire un choix en sachant que quel que
soit le choix qu'il va faire et la
valeur de ma choisir de respecter elles
sont toutes justifiées pour de bonnes
raisons
pensez par exemple au devoir
d'information des fonctionnaires et à
l'obligation dans le même temps de
confidentialité c'est pour ça qu'il est
important de sortir d'une démarche qui
serait simplement statique
en dix ans on a un corpus de règles à
respecter au contraire c'est vers une
démarche dynamique de gestion de
l'éthique au quotidien qu'il faut tendre
selon moi afin d'enregistrer un peu plus
mon propos je vais vous donner un
exemple
meetic que j'ai tirée d'un film de ken
loach qui s'appelle mois dane elec et
peut-être que vous serrez la mine and
palme d'or à cannes en 2007
je vous fais un très bref résumé parce
que peut-être que vous n'allez pas
tousser et tout vu le film
dans ce film qui se passe en
grande-bretagne daniel blais qui a un
menuisier de 59 ans à une attaque
cardiaque et donc il est contraint
puisqu'elle ne peut plus travailler
il est contraint de s'inscrire au
chômage s'il veut toucher d'indemnités
je vous passe tous les détails le l'idée
principale du film de ken loach c'est de
dénoncer l'absurdité du système de
protection sociale britannique face aux
démarches administratives que le héros
de l'entrepont dans le dilemme éthique
qui m'intéresse dans ce film il est lié
non pas à la dernière place mais à sa
conseillère pôle emploi en fait c'est
l'équivalent français de ce que dans le
film est un job center en grande
bretagne et cette conseillère pôle
emploi elle s'appelle anne et un jour
dans le film daniel blais qui vise à
voir sa conseillère parce qu'ils doivent
remplir un formulaire en ligne
d'inscriptions au chômage mais problème
dernier blake ne sait pas se servir d'un
ordinateur et dans le film si vous
l'avez vu où vous le verrez
prochainement
anne est assez mal à l'aise vis-à-vis de
de cette demande de la part du héros
parce qu'ils n'ont pas rendez vous donc
en théorie en suivant les règles de
fonctionnement du job center
elle n'a pas à venir l'aider pour
effectuer cette démarche qui est
pourtant obligatoire quel est le dilemme
éthique face auxquels est confronté
notre conseillère pôle emploi et bien il
y a deux types de valeur et sont en
contradiction
d'un côté vous avez laloyaux la loyauté
envers son organisation et de respect de
sa hiérarchie
mais de l'autre on peut aussi considérer
que par son action notre conseillère
peut mettre en avant sa mission de
service public
et la bienveillance vis-à-vis de
l'usager ce qui m'a d'abord de vous
montrer c'est quelle que soit la valeur
qu'elle va choisir de mettre en pratique
à travers son comportement
les deux sont tout à fait justifiées on
attend d'un agent public qu'il respecte
sa hiérarchie cette comportement normal
attendu de tous les agents publics
al'inverse si elle ne respecte pas la
procédure formelle et qu'elle vient
aider le héros à remplir ses obligations
en matière de procédures des demandeurs
à l'emploi c'est aussi un moyen de
remplir au mieux sa mission de service
public vous voyez là qu'il n'y a pas de
solution évidente et c'est pour ça
qu'elle se trouve face à des situations
problématiques et puis qu un malaise je
terminerai simplement en vous disant que
cette hausse est mis face à sète sud à
ces situations à ces situations du
dilemme éthique qui ne relève pas
forcément d'une infraction par rapport à
un orme juridiquement contraignantes
qu'il faut aider les agents publics à
travers un certain nombre de mécanismes
et dispositifs qui vont venir les
accompagner pour faire la meilleure
décision est adoptée la meilleure
conduite possible au quotidien je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]